[Music]  you guys excited about nba playoffs huh  yeah  you know what is even more exciting  though to meet in the nba playoffs and i  gotta tell you this it's the clothes  some of the nba stars have been wearing  to their post-game press conferences  they were the craziest stuff yeah take a  look  i just wanted to win this game real bad  i didn't know we needed this game i  think we really opened up everybody with  cb you know he's starting off shooting  the ball the way he did three months um  just not what we used to really driving  the lane kicking the ball out the  perimeter hitting our outside shots our  bigs worked it they grabbed the glass we  controlled the tempo that way  after that time out we just couldn't get  it  you know they got too many open looks  you gotta distribute the ball a little  better and uh you know play don't play  so selfishly yeah willis back in the  lineup played fantastic and um  [Applause]  that's real